buonasera chi era qui l'anno scorso
ricorderà che si è parlato di una
stampante 3d che fa delle cose
meravigliose e io voglio presentarvi una
stampante uno di questa sera una
stampante 0.0 e neanche mi va di
chiamare la stampante perché stampante
dall'idea di qualcosa di istantanea
infatti un sostantivo un participio
presente o un gerundio io ricordo
qualcuno a proposito di migrante disse è
un gerundio no è un participio presente
e allora voglio avete buona memoria di
quell'episodio no no
e voglio chiamarla stampatrici perché
dall'idea di qualcosa che produce roba
nel tempo e ve lo presento ecco la linea
la pedalina ormai la chiama così io ho
perso la testa per questa per questa
macchina per questi due quintali e mezzo
di ghisa che si trovano oggi a conselice
in provincia di ravenna e che ho
incontrato il primo ottobre durante una
manifestazione sulla libertà di stampa
questa pedalina ha dato il meglio di sé
dopo l'otto settembre 1943 quando il
fascismo card e misero repubblica di
salò arrivarono i nazisti e il suo
compito era fondamentale quella era
quello di informare di informare di
stampare comunicazioni volantini che poi
sarebbero stati fatti circolare i
protagonisti di questa incredibile
meravigliosa avventura della pedalina
furono i partigiani e partigiane di
antifascisti
assist e del distaccamento umberto ricci
della 28 esima brigata garibaldi e la
maggior parte di quelle persone non non
ci sono più profilate tra luglio e
settembre del 1944
questa è la casa della famiglia
sangiorgi sull'argine del fiume sillaro
ed è stata la prima il primo
nascondiglio della della pedalina era
stata presa a imola da una tipografia in
disuso venne rimessa a posto
sistemata fatta funzionare e venne
portata nello scantinato di questa casa
della famiglia sangiorgi vedete ci sono
gli argini
sullo sfondo della del fiume sillaro e
che voleva dire che questa pedalina
veniva utilizzata spesso da persone che
avevano i piedi nell'acqua
così la ricorda bernardo bernabe uno dei
sopravvissuti e quella era una stanza di
due metri per due
ci si lavora in tanti perché c'erano i
tipografi cioè agli stampatori sono le
persone che venivano a portare la carta
ed inchiostro e poi c'erano le persone
che da lì dovevano portare via i
volantini i materiali gli organi di
informazione richiameremo così
e questo il ricordo che ha fatto
bernardo e me lo ha raccontato il primo
ottobre di quest'anno ha con sé dice
guido buscaroli e la persona che portò
la pedalina dai moran fino a conselice
era un pescivendolo lui ebbe un ruolo
importantissimo era un militante dei gap
un ruolo importantissimo perché non solo
la portò sul suo furgone
ripeto due quintali e mezzo di casa ma
poi era quello che in bicicletta faceva
la spola in continuazione per portare la
carta ed inchiostro e senza le quali la
pedalina
funzionato e si racconta che poi veniva
a prendere i materiali stampati li
portava sempre in bicicletta nascosti
davanti sulla cassetta dove c'erano le
anguille problema è che ogni tanto delle
anguille si muovevano
e allora rischiava di essere scoperto e
questi sono quattro tipografi tipografi
dell'epoca cosa facevano componevano i
metalli a dire stare con i caratteri di
piombo o immaginate la fatica
immaginate la fatica solo di fare un
volantino lettera per lettera carattere
per carattere
eravamo nel 1943 44 e per produrre un
semplice volantino ci volevano le ore
per crearlo con i caratteri di piombo e
poi ci voleva la forza spaventosa dei
pedalatori degli stampatori questi
quattro sono stati trucidati dai nazisti
immaginate che cosa voleva dire per far
passare un foglio farlo inchiostrare
prendere i caratteri bisognava dare sei
colpi di pedale per un foglio solo voi
immaginate che vennero stampate in un
solo giorno ad esempio 25.000 copie del
quotidiano l'unità è che nel periodo in
cui funziona questa pedalina melo
stampata e centinaia di migliaia di
volantini di quotidiani di altro
materiale l'informazione è tutto fatto
con i pedali pedalando grazie alla
fatica di queste persone
questi sono alcuni esempi dei materiali
che venivano stampati sono tutti
raccolti a conselice e mi suggerisco di
dare di andare a visitarla questa
pedalina con tutti i materiali
dell'epoca
questa è un'edizione dell'unità
questo è un volantino dei gruppi di
difesa delle donne le donne partigiane
ebbero un ruolo straordinariamente
importante perché erano le staffette
erano coloro che correvano rischi enormi
nel portare i volantini materiali di
villaggio in villaggio
di città in città di casa in casa per
far conoscere cosa accadeva durante la
guerra per mobilitare all'azione per
dare istruzioni per dare direttive per
dare coraggio soprattutto e e loro
rischiavano di più erano la maggior
parte delle persone che portavano che
diffondevano che facevano informazione
poi c'era tanti stratagemmi appunto
c'era il pesciarolo che sotto la cassa
dei pesci portava i volantini c'era il
farmacista che con la scusa di dover
visitare delle persone in casa portava i
volantini c'era il fruttivendolo che li
nascondeva sotto le cassette di frutta
sono persone che si dipingevano
coprivano i migliori per far vedere che
l'aveva malate tutto questo poi dovendo
passare posti di blocco di nazisti e
nonostante questo ci si riusciva ma ci
si riusciva con una con un coraggio con
una forza con una volontà che che vanno
ricordate che se ci dimentichiamo queste
persone se ci dimentichiamo la pedalina
ci comporteremo la raci comporti a mare
nel presente ci comporteremo maranella
nel futuro e alle donne staffette io
voglio dare un omaggio particolare
ricordando ines bedeschi ines ebbe un
ruolo importantissimo in questa storia
della pedalina perché era non soltanto
una staffetta ma era anche una
formatrice cioè girava per tutta
l'emilia per cercare di spiegare alle
altre donne partigiane come poter fare
quel lavoro come moltiplicare i canali
di informazione come comunicare di
villaggio in villaggio attraverso la
bicicletta superando i posti di blocco
superando la violenza che incontravano
gratuita feroce e brutale dei nazisti in
essa venne torturata in maniera
terribile e morì il 28 marzo del 45 io
voglio chiudere
questo racconto di lina la pedalina con
i versi di renata viganò dedicati a ines
ines era nel fiore della vita è tutta
intera voleva viverla invece l'ha detta
della partigiana ad ogni cosa più cara
rinunciò che non fosse la lotta dalle
sue valli e monti di romagna dove era
maggiore bisogno la presero i nazisti
feroce spaventati la tortura nostra foto
la sua bocca rotta neppure un nome di
accompagno infuriati i tedeschi lavorano
sulla riva del po ma anche in un giorno
di primavera che era fatica morire in
svedesi non senti la voglia di salvarsi
col tradimento
grazie